Benedict xvi's final act as Pope
arguably changed the Catholic Church
more than anything else he'd achieved
during his entire eight year papacy on
February 28 2013 Benedict became the
first pope in nearly 600 years to resign
and with his departure flight over the
rooftops of Rome he officially Left
Behind the Vatican The Enclave where
he'd held key leadership positions for
decades
the official reason for the then 85 year
old's decision was frail health
the Vatican stress Benedict didn't
suffer from any specific Illness but
even by 2011 his physical deterioration
was obvious and he had to use a wheeled
platform to make his way down the long
aisle of Saint Peter's Basilica
arteries last months have felt my
energies declining and Abbas got
insistently in prayer to grant me his
light and to help me make the right
decision loving the church means also
Having the courage to make difficult and
painful decisions always looking to the
good of the church and not of oneself
Benedict was elected Pope in 2005. his
reputation as a hardliner earned him the
sobrike God's Rottweiler he was a
traditionalist with strict views on
Catholic Doctrine but his was a troubled
paper scene Benedict certainly made
numerous efforts to tackle the global
problem of child sex abuse by Catholic
clergy but he was also criticized for
his own past failures and inadequate
handling of abuse cases
and in 2012 documents leaked by his
Butler in the vatile league Scandal
revealed a Papal Administration riddled
with factional power struggles and
Financial mismanagement
I was at both conclaves and there was a
very different feeling a very different
dynamic in the 2013 one it was as if
Benedict the 16th by by retiring by
standing down simply handed over a job
you know that was that was that needed
to be done straight away he handed over
as it were an inbox you know that was
very clear
um and so the Cardinals were able to say
right this is what needs doing who is
the best person to do the job
the full reasons for Benedict's
resignation may never be known but the
message of Reform that it seemed to send
is credited with profoundly influencing
the Cardinal's choice of Pope Francis as
Benedict's successor